[Music]
jeff is in cincinnati hi jeff how are
you
hi dave how are you i'm good good how
can i help
dave um i'm 51 years old um i work in a
dying industry and
we are going to our plants going to shut
down and at the latest it's going to
stay open is 2027 but it could shut
sooner than that
i'm debt-free
but i don't have a lot uh saved for
retirement um just wondering what i
should do
so that i can retire
decent
okay well uh you're probably going to be
working more than five more years if you
have zero save for retirement
right but but
i mean
um i i make a good living i
gross about
165 000 a year okay um
so what are you gonna do when the plant
shuts down in five years
well i was planning on what i was
planning on doing is
um
starting a greenhouse
and working for myself
okay
all right
and what can you make doing that
where i live probably
somewhere in the neighborhood of
thousand fifty thousand a year
substantial drop from 165
yes
okay
so that's really going that's not going
to really assist you in building a nest
egg because you're telling me you have
no nest egg right
well i have i mean my home's paid for i
have eight and a half acres of land
that's paid for
but you don't have any money invested in
a nest egg for retirement
i got i got a small pigeon probably
it'll be about 50 000 a year but you
don't have any money invested in
retirement
no not a whole lot 20 000 in a 401k okay
all right so since you have no bills
and you have five years with this
fabulous income
let's turn up the heat man
max out max out your 401k
max out your roth iras are you married
yes
okay what's she make
she she's she doesn't work she has a lot
of health issues okay so you make 165
000 max out two individual roth iras max
out your 401k that's about 40 000 bucks
a year right there
okay and and let's just turn up the heat
and let's see how much money we can get
saved in the next five years i mean
let's just pretend that you saved uh 50
000 bucks for five years that'd be 250
000
in your in your retirement account when
you when the plant shuts down
okay and while you're at it you need to
pile up enough cash to build this
greenhouse for cash
all right over the next five years so
you need you got two goals here that you
need to budget for and you need to
really lean in on that so here's the
thing
if you put 250 000 in there and you
don't ever save anything else
every seven years or so it will double
if it's in good mutual funds
okay and so let's see you said you're 51
5 years of 56
so at 63 it'll be 500
at 70 it'll be a million
all right but you need that 250 in there
in the next five years so you need to
say 50 000 or more a year start with
maxing out all your retirement get with
our smart investor pro in your area and
get this game plan laid out you've done
a really good job of putting some basic
assets in your life that paid for real
estate stuff that's amazing now let's
put some cash in there to eat with my
man and you'll be in much better
condition
attitude wise when this plant goes
shutting down on you